alexis poulain bonjour bienvenue dans la
matinale de rtl france alors à la
question de la fermeture des frontières
avec cette crise sanitaire on s'en
souvient les faits le débat lors de la
première vague mais cette fois on le
constate c'est une réaction rapide
notamment de la france pour stopper ses
liaisons avec le royaume uni est ce
qu'on peut dire que la france l'europe
en général à tirer des conclusions de la
première vague
je crois qu'il ya des leçons apprises de
cette première vague notamment sur la
circulation du virus via les aéroports
les gares etc
mais encore une fois c'est une réaction
tardive de la france les pays-bas ont
d'abord décidé d'agir les premiers
l'allemagne aussi très rapidement s'est
alignée et puis les françaises sont 18
un conseil de défense en urgence et puis
stoppons tous les allées et venues entre
france et royaume uni mais seulement
pour 48 heures donc c'est une période
tampon pour s'organiser
comme le disait le porte-parole gabriela
talent reste que la gare du nord a été
ouvert à tous vents et les eurostar
étaient bondées puisque dès que boris
johnson a annoncé la mise sous
quarantaine
enfin le confinement de londres et la
région sud de l'angleterre il ya eu un
exode massif
donc on a eu pendant des journées
entières d arriver sans test sans
mesures particulières de personnes qui
revenaient du royaume uni pour les faits
tout simplement qu'ils décident de fuir
la période de confinement en grande
bretagne en france
amsterdam mais aussi bruxelles donc
c'est un peu trop tard encore une fois
on voit que les partenaires européens
réagissent dans l'urgence
jamais dans la planification et cette
fois ci il décide d'être coordonnées je
pense que le break site n'est pas pour
rien c'est aussi peut-être là bas moyen
de faire passer un message politique
également puisque cette gestion crise
sanitaire
elle est d'abord et avant tout une
gestion politique plutôt que sanitaire
oui parce que effectivement les
dernières discussions sur le break site
ont lieu en ce moment on le rappelle la
fin c'est prévu pour le 31 décembre
vous pensez réellement qu'il ya un
message ici qui peut être envoyée au
royaume uni par l'europe avec cette
décision quasi unanime stopper les
liaisons avec le royaume uni
oui je pense qu'il ya un message parce
que
clairement l'idée est de montrer un
visage uni face à une grande bretagne
isolé pour accélérer les négociations
pour tordre un peu le coup de boris
johnson
parce que lui aimerait jouer au
contraire sur la division à s'assurer un
deal avec les pays bas avec la france
avec l'allemagne et c'est donc là montré
que tous d'un coup faire les grands
partenaires les grands pays décide la
même chose
c'est peut-être un moyen de dire
attention ce n'est que le début et la
suite risque d'être encore plus
douloureuse quand on voit d'ailleurs les
files de camions entre calais et douvres
qui ne font que que s'accumuler depuis
quelques jours parce que les grandes
magasin faisait des stocks parce qu'ils
avaient de noël parce qu'on avait peur
d'un no deal à partir du 1er janvier
là avec l'arrêt de des échanges entre la
france et le royaume uni ça va être une
catastrophe pour le secteur du transport
et pour ses camions qui sont bloqués à
la frontière on en parle peu y'a pas que
les passagers d'agrément est aussi le
commerce qui va beaucoup en souffrir
alors la nouvelle souche est un cas a
été détecté également en italie hier
dans ce contexte qu'est ce que vous
attendez du gouvernement français quel
type d'anticipation à ce qu'il faut déjà
s'attendre un nouveau reconfirme en une
certaine forme de confinement dans dans
les semaines à venir
oui on a l'impression de toute façon que
on est déjà en train de préparer
l'opinion publique à un peu de temps
ciel retentissement qui était déjà prévu
de toute façon avant le déconfinement
certains mêmes parlent de plusieurs
vagues successives en 2021
on voit que ce virus a muté puisque le
problème de la grande bretagne c'est une
mutation du virus qui le rend plus
virulent qu'il est plus contagieux d'une
certaine façon pas plus dangereux a
priori donc sans doute qu'on nous
prépare déjà à 10 rebonds et bien il est
fait c'était bien c'était une parenthèse
enchantée entre guillemets maintenant
retour au bercail ombreux confine on
remet des autorisations de sortie on
recommence cette folie du coronavirus
virus qui rappelons le
même si les
virulent extrêmement dangereuse à un
taux de mortalité que de 0 05 % pour les
moins de 60 ans avec un vaccin qui
arrivent dont on connaît peu de choses
vaccin qui est annoncé à 95% efficace
qui permettrait de peut-être limiter la
contagion ce n'est pas sûre mais où
d'avoir une forme bénigne de cette
maladie quelqu'un pour beaucoup
asymptomatiques ou qui vont à un virus
comme le président actuellement
c'est-à-dire grippe sévère mais pas
quelque chose qui vous emmène aux
urgences ou en réanimation
donc on est on est en train de faire
quelque chose d'assez inédit il y avait
là le témoignage de ces voyageurs
bloqués à l'hôpital de berlin c'est
d'abord et avant tout comme je le disais
une gestion politique de contrôle des
populations on force les gens à faire
des choses qu'ils ne décident pas plutôt
que de contrôle sanitaire si on était
sérieux intense points de plus avec ce
virus on aurait bloqué les frontières
bien avant on aurait fait des
confirmands réel qui aurait duré
peut-être à moi et ça suffisait à
arrêter la circulation du virus
là on essaie de faire en sorte que le
virus circule toujours un peu mais pas
trop mais sans réel plan sanitaire on
n'a pas non plus aidé l'hôpital avoir
davantage de moyens on n'a pas mis en
place de protocoles avec la médecine de
ville avec les cliniques privées
et puis y'a il reste bien sûr cette
fameuse question de la vaccination non
obligatoire
heureusement mais à savoir comment elle
va être organisé voilà la vraie question
aujourd'hui on voit certains pays qui
s'organise à avec des pas des sortes de
vaccinodromes puisque le vaccin doit
être stoppée à moins de 80 degrés en
france on ne voit rien de ce type là
d'être en train de s'organiser on a
beaucoup de d'annonce comme quoi on va
aller vite commencer dès la fin de
l'année mais on ne sait pas comment tout
cela va se mettre en place
alors justement on a vu une certaine
unité des pays européens à s'organiser
face à cette nouvelle souche du
coronavirus vous parliez du vaccin est
ce qu'on peut s'attendre une
coordination différente désormais des
pays européens pour faire face à une
éventuelle troisième vague et puis pour
mais la mise en place d'une campagne de
vaccination alors déjà oui sur la
vaccination les pays européens se sont
mis d'accord et veulent une campagne
coordonnée entre l'italie l'allemagne et
la france a été annoncée
le problème encore une fois c'est le
nombre de doses de vaccins qui ont été
commandés a priori pas assez pour ces
trois pays avec une lutte entre france
et allemagne où les français voulaient
pousser pour avoir le vaccin sanofi mais
qui a pris du retard
il ya aussi ce prix des vaccins qui pose
question puisque les autorités
européennes négociées avec les
laboratoires sans transparence aucune
donc le prix peut varier de un euro à 15
euros la dose en fonction de modern
aoudou de pfizer
on demanderait davantage de transparence
ce serait la moindre des choses pour une
campagne de cette ampleur et puis une
fois encore je pense que cette
coordination européenne est là pour
marquer le pas pour montrer au royaume
uni qu'il est seul et isolé et que du
côté du continent ça s'organise
même si ce n'est pas le cas on voit bien
que les mesures sont toujours prises
dans l'urgence toujours pris en fonction
du voisin on regarde un peu ce qui se
passe mais on a pas d'unité qu'ovide
réel à bruxelles qui gérerait pour
l'ensemble des pays européens
donc on est toujours dans une urgence et
un temps de retard par rapport à ce
virus qui est inquiétant c'est que
d'autres régions du monde reparte
notamment l'asie la chine s'est même
s'il ya encore ce virus toujours mais on
a l'impression que l'europe s'enfonce
dans une crise qui va durer on parle de
vagues successives à répétition mais
surtout une crise économique dont on ne
connaît pas encore l'ampleur avec des
mesures de l'union européenne pour
essayer de sauver les banques de leurs
mauvaises pratiques dès l'an prochain
plus de ces lois qui sont votées dans
l'urgence en ce moment pour permettre de
mettre en place un système de bad bank
pour éviter que les dettes privées qui
vont s'accumuler ne provoque pas la
faillite des banques
merci beaucoup alexis poulain
éditorialiste pour rt france